et puis à ma droite elisabeth badinter
deutsche bahn à terre alors vous êtes
marié trois enfants je pense est
important il faut le dire dans cette
émission vous est agrégé de philosophie
vous êtes vous en vous dirigez un
séminaire de l'histoire de la famille à
l'école polytechnique et vous n'êtes
publié sous le titre l'amour en plus aux
éditions flammarion
une histoire de l'amour naturel du 17e
au 20e siècle et vous montrer ça va
quand même surprendre beaucoup de gens
nous ont montré qu'au xviie siècle et
ben l'amour maternel ça n'existait
quasiment pas dans les familles
françaises en tout cas alors à quoi vous
voyez vous quelles sont les preuves que
vous pouvez avancer et que vous avancez
elles sont prêtes très nombreuses dans
ce livre et sont les preuves de lille à
nos existences cet amour maternel
alors je veux dire que de toute façon il
ya eu des femmes à toutes les époques
qui ont aimé leur enfant alors si on
peut dire qu'au 17e et une certaine
indifférence une différence réelle ça ne
veut pas dire que toutes les femmes
n'ont pas aimé leur enfant jusqu à le
dire parce que l'amour ça existait
depuis touche mais dans l'antiquité
il ya des mères pélican qui se sacrifie
pour leurs enfants donc ça existe depuis
toujours mais il est vrai qu'au xviie
siècle on assiste à un certain rejet de
l'enfant qui se manifeste par différents
signes et je crois que pour parler
d'amour il faut rechercher les preuves
d'amour quand les preuves sont pas là il
faut conclure qu'il ya pas tellement
d'amour au xviie siècle
effectivement tous les signes d'amour
nous échappe par exemple à une époque
mortalité infantile extraordinaire et où
le lait de la mère est un facteur une
grande chance de survie pour l'enfant et
bien on constate que dans les villes
surtout dans les villes les maires
refusent de nourrir leurs enfants
elle refuse de les nourrir et elle les
abandonne presque aussitôt né dans les
bras d'une nourrice personnel ça c'est
quand même assez frappant quand vous
ajoutez même quelque chose qui est
encore plus choquant c'est que vous
dites finalement les familles en juillet
ont choisi ce avec plus d'attention le
cuisinier de la nourrice oui le
cuisinier la femme de chambre c'est
important ça oui mais la nourrice
finalement c'est pas bien mais quand on
regarde comment choisissait les
nourrissons ne pas manquer d'être frappé
aujourd'hui je veux dire qu'on a confié
on confie son enfant à n'importe qui
quelquefois des femmes dont on ne
connaît pas l'adresse des fans qui ne
savent pas écrire s'ils savent pas lire
et pour beaucoup d'enfants c'est la mort
assurée vous racontez même des meneurs
chargé de cette nourrisson qui en perd
en route une autre une autre fois ce une
des femmes chargées trois nouveau nés
qui ne sait pas de qui elle les tient de
cette lignée pas quelle valeur mais qui
va nourrir ses enfants ne sais pas et
donc ça prouve quand même sur une
nonchalance de la paire des mers et
autant on peut comprendre que les femmes
qui n'avaient pas du tout les moyens de
garder leurs enfants pour le cas c'était
presque une mesure de survie se
débarrasser des enfants autant on peut
comprendre leur attitude parce qu'elle
n'avait pas le choix autant comprend mal
l'attitude de ces femmes qui avaient
tous les moyens qui elle n'avait rien à
faire et qui ont fait de même
et d'ailleurs c'est elle qui ont donné
l'exemple je veux dire que au xiiie
siècle 14e siècle et première femme qui
se débarrassent de leurs enfants ce sont
les grandes aristocrate donc vraiment
celle qui est qu'ils n'ont aucune excuse
si l'on peut dire qu'ils sont vraiment
des draps c est ce que vous montrez bien
c'est que toutes ces femmes finalement
n'ont jamais eu aucun contact avec leurs
enfants alors vous êtes montrés
évidemment les abandonnent les nourrices
qui après quand ces enfants viennent à
la maison vers l'âge de 4 ou 5 ans ben
on les confie à des précepteurs laissé
pour les classes privilégiées sûr mais
si on considère que l'amour se tissent
au fil des jours entre la mère et son
enfant effectivement il est d'abord
quatre ans d'absence
et puis quand l'enfant revient la maison
est ce que vous imaginez ça il trouve
quelqu'un qui connaît pas qui est
sommaire parce qu'il n'a jamais vu et on
peut et on pourrait imaginer que la mer
à ce moment-là reçoit son enfant avec
tendresse et en ce qui concerne des
classes ce privilégié ce n'est pas le
cas effectivement les femmes se re
débarrassent de leurs enfants auprès de
gouvernante de précepteur et elle voit
l'ensemble extrêmement peu dans la
journée on a ce sentiment tient pas
vraiment de lien entre la mère l'enfant
pourra pas se mettre le collège une
suspension bien un couvent et enfin bref
donc il n'ya pas de décompte macabre est
en visite on cherche un mari pour cent
et fait ça et puis chez les pauvres
évidemment l'arrivée d'un enfant
d'enfants supplémentaires c'est pas
tellement bien accueilli par ce sont des
bouches à nourrir ce sont des oui je
crois qu'on ne peut rien conclure à
partir du comportement des gens très
pauvres et dieu sait s'ils sont nombreux
et si la pauvreté terrible au 17e et
même au 18e
par conséquent je crois que si on peut
montrer quelque chose sur l'amour
maternel c'est plutôt à partir des
femmes qui ont le choix qu à partir de
celles qui n'ont pas le choix vous
réunit la cdu mais c'est très bien où
dit quand on regarde les trois actes de
l'éducation mise en nourrice gouvernante
ou précepteur et départ au collège on
peut on ne peut pas ne pas voir l'idée
directrice qui préside
comment s'en débarrasser en gardant la
tête haute comme résumé bien le parce
que mettre son enfant est dans un
collège et le mettre un terme
ces quelques pas encore une fois s'en
débarrasser mais avec excuse que c'est
pour le bien de l'enfant
là il va recevoir une éducation morale
et l'instruction et on peut quand même
être se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi vraiment cet internat pourquoi
les parents n'ont pas gardé avec leurs
enfants après tout ils pouvaient ou
transmettre les valeurs morales
religieuses et envoyer les enfants népal
interne
et pourtant le l'internât n'est et au
design au xviiie se développe de façon
prodigieuse
alors on peut y voir une facteur de
moralisation de l'enfance comme philippe
ariès
mais on peut aussi se demander si on
aime vraiment beaucoup quelqu'un n'a pas
envie de s'en séparer
enfin c'est comme ça qu'on raisonne
aujourd'hui françoise renaudot vous
faites est ce que sur un échantillon
aussi peu représentatif on peut conclure
une
quand même pas sûr enfin parce que si
vous examinez les ctas privilégie
aujourd'hui vous avez exactement le même
phénomène
les femmes ne lève pas leurs enfants ce
sont plus des nourrices mais sont des
narces ce sont des bonnes qui son équipe
où des jeunes filles au pair
éventuellement même dans un milieu un
peu moins et même un peu moins riche
mais c'est le même phénomène les femmes
qui ont le temps ne s'occupent pas de
leurs enfants
donc vous comptez s'en est finalement là
je proteste absolument que l'instinct
maternel disparaît d'abord parce que je
pense que l'époque sur laquelle a
travaillé j'y rêve de l'inter est
d'abord très courte
deuxièmement la musique c'est pas rien
c'est 3 17e 18e 19e
on va quand même quand même en plus
souvent à cette étude repose sur un
milieu totalement urbain est presque
uniquement axé sur paris et lyon non pas
du tout c'est plaisant de paris gens que
j'ai pu aussi des tas d'exemples de
petites villes de moyenne importance
nouvelle rivale à 12 da prince de la
france rurale qui très très important de
l'homme si elles concernent d'abord
c'est un phénomène urbain c'est vrai en
majorité humaine et c'est vrai que ça ce
qu'on fait dans toutes les places de la
ville de la plus riche à la moyenne
bourgeoisie la grande bourgeoisie aux
petits bourgeois aux petits artisans
petits marchands donc tout à fait la
même absolument générale dans les villes
en ce qui concerne la classe paysanne et
qui représente effectivement 80% des
gens aux 17e et 18e siècles
c'est vrai que les paysans dans leur
grande majorité ont gardé leurs enfants
mais c'est vrai aussi que tous ne l'ont
pas fait non seulement les plus pauvres
les journaliers qui sont obligés de se
débarrasser de leurs enfants
il faut compter aussi toutes les femmes
paysannes qui sont accepté de se séparer
de leurs enfants pour venir nourrir les
enfants des villes et l'a dans l'os a
fait finalement beaucoup de gens qui ont
abandonné leurs enfants avec
effectivement vous le dit très bien il y
avait beaucoup de nourrice et que c'est
nourrissent venait de la campagne alors
on peut penser que c'est nourrice était
assez misérable pour d'abord nourrir les
enfants des autres avant de nourrir le
leur mais ce que ce je serais d'accord
avec françoise renaudot pour dire que
moi ce qui m'a aussi frappé d'abord je
trouve que c'est un travail tout à fait
considérable que vous avez fait et
comme ça en lectrice très moyenne c'est
ce que je représente tout à fait je me
suis dit est ce que vraiment il est
possible par exemple de parler des
femmes de classe presque pas moyen de 10
en dessous de la moyenne celle dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure nous n'avons
finalement et d'ailleurs vous le dites
vous même ou plutôt vous le dit pas mais
il n'y a pas de témoignage à ce moment
là mais si vous en avez de ces femmes le
si vous en avez regardé les tableaux de
le nain il ya toujours un enfant qui a
toujours il y a une onde un diagnostic
historique de la production culturelle
et ça c'est quelque chose de fabuleux
parce que vous regardez à tableau vous
regardez vous lisez un livre de l'époque
et vous avez toujours un enfant et
particulièrement la campagne et c'est
tout à fait dans la peinture de l'époque
vous avez toujours des enfants ils
soient pas que l'iconographie ne dit pas
tout et effectivement à la fin du xviiie
il ya une grande production picturale ou
aux montants font la 17e à la nacelle 10
nm est nommé puisque le changement
s'opère mon avis au 18e il ya
effectivement une grand position
pictural avec l'enfant au milieu je ne
crois pas que ça 10 le taux du sentiment
maternel
je crois aussi qu'il y a en ce qui
concerne la ville des modes et c'est
vrai qu'à la campagne
les femmes ont gardé leurs enfants alors
bon c'est vrai qu'on voit les enfants
dans les jupes de la merde moi je ne
discute pas ni des modes ni d
fait c'est ce que je mets en doute c'est
la conclusion que vous tirées d'une
étude sur un échantillon
l'autre argument qui intervient dans
l'interview finalement il y avait une
mortalité infantile qui était
considérable alors tout est gratuit
alors effectivement les enfants
mouraient il y avait c'était un
phénomène normal donc on s'attache est
peut-être moins a su ces sensations 10
et 9 mois vous contestez voilà est-ce
que je vous contestez qui le problème
quel problème qu'est ce que vous jouez
conteste le la conclusion que vous direz
il fait de la mise en nourrissant
m'interdisant nourrit ce n'est pas une
preuve d'un amour ni de d'absence
d'instinct maternel
comptez vous c'est que le fait que je
dise qu'il n'ya pas d'instinct maternel
saissac voie lactée est sur les bases
sur lesquelles vous vous vous reposez
pour dire il n'y a pas d' instable
interpelle vous contestez complètement
loin andré langage oral à gagner dans
son livre démontre d'une façon sur un
plan biologique et génétique que
l'instinct maternel et la suite de
l'instinct de reproduction